et pour en parler avec nous marc
lavergne spécialiste de la corne de
l'afrique bonjour merci d'être en direct
avec nous sur rt france addis abeba a
donc lancé une opération militaire
contre le tigre et les
télécommunications sont coupés sur place
alors que c'est ton que savez-vous des
combats qui s'y déroulent
on fait plutôt un effet puisque les
communications sont coupées
que ce soit les communications et
retiennent que ce soit les
communications par par la route 1 le
tigre est est une région
disons qui est située tout achat au nord
de l'ethiopie coller à la frontière de
l'erythrée qui est une frontière fermée
et puis aussi au soudan mais là aussi
c'est une région difficile d'accès donc
on a très peu d'informations sur ce qui
se déroule en fait c'est cette guerre
n'est pas quelque chose d'inattendu
c'est quelque chose qui se préparait
depuis fort longtemps avec la
constitution aux tigres et d'une base
arrière en quelque sorte pour les
dirigeants pigrée 1 qui avait été évincé
de pouvoir depuis quelques années et
j'avais un sentiment comme ça et les
traits qui crée un de revanche à l'égard
des gens qui étaient au pouvoir addis
abeba donc les menaces de guerre sont
anciennes et on passe maintenant aux
actes et ça sera le gain effectivement
comme ça a été dit extrêmement que
dévastatrice je pense pour les deux
camps c'est un conflit est à l'arrêt
depuis plusieurs années vous le rappeler
mais qu'est ce qui a généré tout à coup
cette escalade des tensions
mais je crois que d'une part c'est
l'impression que les tigres et un
peuvent avoir que ils ne reprendront pas
le pouvoir
addis abeba la capitale de l'ensemble de
l'ethiopie pouvoir qui l'ont détenue
depuis 1991
jusqu'à ces dernières années jusqu'à
l'arrivée d'abby remède au pouvoir au
poste de premier ministre
donc les tigres et 1 se sont installés
c'est un mouvement de guérilla au départ
tu as été créée par l'erythrée et pour
déstabiliser le pouvoir d'addis abeba
ils ont plus de pouvoir à la chute de
l'urss en 1991 et depuis lors ils ont
fait fortune
ils sont devenus un peu un élément
central dans l'âme
dans la composition de l'ethiopie ils
s'en sont sentis est resté et il cherche
à prendre leur revanche
non pas tellement en reprenant à addis
abeba et le pouvoir central
mais en développant un une envie
d'indépendance qui est assez paradoxal
parce que c'est un pays qui n'a pas de
ressources qui est isolé qui est qu'il
n'a pas de frontière maritime et qui est
entouré de pays qui sont eux mêmes en
guerre l'erythrée d'un côté les copies
de l'autre quand j'ai dit en guerre ça
veut dire qu'il ya beaucoup de
contentieux qui ne sont pas réglés entre
ces pays
donc c'est quelque chose d'assez
aventureux en apparence que ce repli de
tous ses cadres tigréens dans leur
région ou pour qui la vente déclenché
cette guerre avec une arme et utilisons
qui est assez solide puisque finalement
les cadres de l'armée ceux qui se sont
vraiment battus c'est eux les héritiers
du front de libération du peuple du
tigré donc aussi bien les dirigeants les
généraux les cadres de l'armée
éthiopienne était des tigres est en
grande partie rejoint leur région
d'origine pour se battre contre l'armée
nationale qui elle est assez dépourvu de
cabre finalement et de gens aguerris au
combat est-ce qu'on a des négociations
sont en cours entre ces deux camps ou
bien elles sont tout simplement
inenvisageable pour le gouvernement
éthiopien
il ya un effet effectivement deux
confrontations assumer des deux côtés en
disant on va faire la guerre mais d'un
autre côté il faut pas oublier tout de
même que les tigres et un ton et des
éthiopiens et ils ont même été à
l'origine de l'histoire de l'ethiopie ya
maintenant près de deux mille ans axoum
la capitale des premier empereur
d'ethiopie et bien elle est située au
tigré c'était des tigres et un le
christianisme éthiopien aussi peiné au
tigre et donc il y a des relations qui
perdure entre les dirigeants vient la
population du tigre et et la population
du reste de l'ethiopie ray puisse du
côté de l'erythrée c'est pareil aussi
parce que du côté de l'erythrée il faut
bien voir que la moitié de la population
érythréenne et tigréenne même s'il ya
aussi là beaucoup de
discorde dont ce n'est pas une guerre
vraiment à proprement parler ethnique
puisque les tigres et un d'ethiopie et
les tigres et un d'erythrée qui sont
séparés par une petite rivière qui
traverse à pied sont en confrontation
également alors que en erythrée en
ethiopie il ya une sorte de mosaïque
ethnique très complexe où il ya d'autres
guerres en train de d'émerger dans tout
le territoire de l'ethiopie finalement
qui est une fédération ethnique
et puis il ya des éléments extérieurs
qui peuvent aussi être intéressés à
démembrer cette ethiopie ou du moins à
l'affaiblir parce que c'est 100 millions
d'habitants c'est un géant d'afrique
tu es aussi le siège de l'union
africaine dont sept à pouvoir qui a une
importance considérable et on on sait
avec cette histoire de barrage sur le
nil
les difficultés qui actuellement entre
l'egypte et l'ethiopie dont il ya
peut-être des intérêts aussi extérieurs
qui peuvent venir essayer peut-être de
d'attiser ces flammes qui se déclenchent
soutirer est alors d'un mot qui pourrait
intervenir pour empêcher justement ce
conflit entre l'ethiopie et la région du
tigré l'onu l'union africaine comment
réagit selon vous la communauté
internationale la communauté
internationale elle et elle est passée
embarrassé par ce qui se passe dans
cette région et personne n'a vraiment la
main l'union africaine vous l'avez
évoqué elle a son siège à addis abeba la
capitale de l'ethiopie
donc elle est assez dans une situation
un peu délicate l'arabie saoudite les
émirats arabes unis sont des pays qui
regardent la mer rouge et tout ce qui se
passe autour de la mer rouge les
inquiète
vincent coûté la puissance émergente de
l'ethiopie est quelque chose qui gêne
est d'une certaine manière
l'arabie saoudite 1 l'arabie saoudite a
a exclu l'ethiopie des pays riverains de
la mer rouge
quand elle a fait cette organisation il
ya maintenant deux ans et l'erythrée en
fin de week-end venez d'hérité c'était
effectivement frontalière le dernier
tube qui est bien et les emiriens les
indiens eux peuvent jouer un rôle pour
pacifier ces deux pays parce que il y
aurait certainement des effets néfastes
aussi sur la péninsule arabique qui la
guerre se prolonger
merci beaucoup d'avoir pris le temps de
répondre à nos questions marc lavergne
je rappelle que vous êtes spécialiste de
la corne de l'afrique